So Sarah was a college graduate, 22, just moved to San Francisco, broke. And while waiting for the bus on Geary Street, she called a friend. But actually, I can't tell you what the friend said without first warning you that the content of the friend's advice might not be suitable for younger listeners. In fact, the content of most of today's program-- it's This American Life by the way. I'm Ira Glass-- may not be suitable for younger listeners. Today's program is Stories of Three Women and the Sex Industry.
莎拉当时22岁，刚大学毕业，搬到旧金山，身无分文。在吉里街等公交车时，她给朋友打了个电话。但我不能在没提醒你的情况下告诉你那个朋友说了什么，因为这段建议的内容可能不适合年轻听众。事实上，今天节目的大部分内容——顺便说一句，这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯——可能都不适合年轻听众。今天的节目是关于三个女性和性产业的故事。
So Sarah's on the street, needs a job. Calls her friend from college. Her friend says, come do phone sex with me.
莎拉当时流落街头，需要一份工作。她给大学的朋友打了电话。朋友说，来和我一起做电话性服务吧。
And so I went to her house that night and we got drunk and took phone sex calls. And I did it for the first time and I was really good at it. And we made like $80.
那天晚上我去了她家，我们喝了酒，开始接电话性服务的来电。这是我第一次做，而且我真的很擅长。我们大概赚了80美元。
And what was it like that first night? What instructions did she give you?
那第一晚感觉如何？她给了你什么指示？
She gave me a list of dirty words. It wasn't even a list, it was like just this collage.
她给了我一张脏话清单。那甚至不算清单，就像是一个拼贴画。
Typed or handwritten?
打印的还是手写的？
Handwritten. And just every single word that's associated with sex, either profanity or you know just words like "wet" and "hot" and "steamy." And she said that if you got lost, you could really just string them together. And she was really, really, really funny.
手写的。上面全是和性有关的词，要么是粗话，要么就是像“湿”、“热”、“刺激”之类的词。她说如果你不知道说什么，就把这些词串起来就行。她真的，真的，真的很有趣。
The guys on the phone seemed like the normal range of guys you meet, Sarah says. Some unlikable, maybe 20% she felt like she could have been friends with. Another 10% that she really liked. She would do calls where she was supposed to dominate the man and calls where she was supposed to be black or Asian.
莎拉说，电话里的那些男人看起来和你平时遇到的男人差不多。有些很讨人厌，大约20%的人她觉得本可以成为朋友。另外10%的人她真的很喜欢。她有时会接那种需要支配男人的电话，有时则是假装自己是黑人或亚裔。
You could just sort of do this accent. It was incredibly un-PC. But you could just sort of do this accent which approximated like a guy in Nebraska's idea of what it is that an Asian woman talks like and they would believe you.
你可以随便模仿某种口音。这非常政治不正确。但你只要模仿那种内布拉斯加州男人心目中亚裔女性说话的样子，他们就会相信你。
OK. So for example, if you were to say something to me in this accent. For example, describe where you're sitting right now as this Asian woman.
好的。那么，举个例子，如果你能用这种口音对我说点什么。比如，描述一下你现在作为一个亚裔女性正坐在哪里。
You know, I really--
你知道，我真的——
Your dignity will preclude you from doing that?
你的尊严让你无法那样做吗？
Yes, it will. It really will. I don't have that much dignity, but I can't do that.
是的，确实如此。真的会。我虽然没那么有尊严，但我做不到。
Well, I will respect that.
好吧，我尊重这一点。
I also had a British accent, which was really, really awful which I modeled after the woman on LA Law.
我当时还会模仿英国口音，真的非常非常糟糕，我是照着《洛杉矶法律》里的那个女人学的。
Come on, let's here that.
来吧，让我们听听。
No, I'm not going to do it for you. How was that? That wasn't very good. The guy in the control room in sort of shaking his head at me. I want you to unzip your pants for me. Please, darling.
不，我不会为你表演的。刚才那个怎么样？表现得不太好。控制室里的那个家伙正冲我摇头。请帮我解开裤子，亲爱的。
All right, you can stop right there. It's public broadcasting.
好了，到此为止吧。这是公共广播。
She did phone sex for a year, then got a job as a naked dancer. She did this for two years. She said that she hurt her back dancing for hours in high heels. She hated her bosses. Every now and then a customer would say something mean to her. But she really, really liked the women she worked with. And on a Saturday night, she would have a better time dancing naked at her job to loud music than say, going to a party with her friends.
她做了一年电话性服务，然后找了一份裸体舞者的工作。她干了两年。她说因为穿着高跟鞋跳舞好几个小时，她的背受了伤。她讨厌她的老板。偶尔会有顾客对她说刻薄的话。但她真的很喜欢和她一起工作的女同事。在周六晚上，她宁愿在工作中伴着大声的音乐跳裸舞，也不愿去和朋友聚会。
Because everyone kept trying to tell me, oh, you know, you really hate this job. And you just don't know that you hate it. But I couldn't feel that I hated it. I called my sort of like closest friend and said, do you think it's stupid that I'm doing this? Like I don't feel like I don't like this job. I feel like I like it. I get up in the morning and I go to it and I don't mind. And he was like, well, if you feel like you like it, then you probably do. That was sort of a ramble. But I guess what I'm trying to say is there were really, really crappy things about it, but it was so far from the worst job that I've ever had.
因为每个人都一直在试图告诉我，哦，你知道，你其实很讨厌这份工作。你只是不知道自己讨厌它。但我感觉不到自己讨厌它。我打电话给我最亲近的朋友说，我做这个是不是很傻？我觉得我不讨厌这份工作。我觉得我喜欢它。我早上起床去上班，我不介意。他说，好吧，如果你觉得你喜欢它，那你就可能真的喜欢。我有点语无伦次了。但我想说的是，这份工作确实有很多糟糕的地方，但它远非我做过最烂的工作。
Really? What was a worse job than this?
真的吗？还有什么比这更烂的工作？
I'm just going to stop the tape right here. I'm just going to stop the tape and come in live to give you a moment to consider what that worse job might be before she gives her answer. OK, are we all thinking now? All right, here we go.
我现在要停下录音。我要暂停录音，现场给你一点时间考虑一下那份更烂的工作是什么，然后再听她的回答。好了，大家都在思考了吗？好，我们开始吧。
Being a grant writer for the Central Park Conservancy.
在中央公园保护协会做拨款申请撰稿人。
Being a grant writer? A job I myself have done.
做拨款申请撰稿人？我自己也做过这份工作。
She said she didn't like working in an office. She didn't like taking orders. Being naked in front of strangers was preferable to taking orders.
她说她不喜欢在办公室工作。她不喜欢听命于人。在陌生人面前裸体比听人差遣更好。
She says if you want to understand what this job is like, she says it's really-- for her anyway-- not that different than other service industry jobs that she's had.
她说如果你想了解这份工作是什么样的，她说——至少对她而言——这和其他她做过的服务业工作没什么不同。
I think it was like day-to-day, just pretty much like any job that's not a great job. It's like waitressing. There are some days where you're waitressing and you're going, oh, this is pretty cool. I'm making pretty good money. I'm working out on the patio today. It's nice out. And some days were like, if I have to ask one more person what they want on their hamburger, I'm going to shoot myself.
我觉得日复一日，这和任何一份普通的工作没什么两样。就像做服务员。有时候你做服务员会觉得，噢，这还挺酷的。我赚了不少钱。我今天在露台上干活。天气很好。但有时会觉得，如果我必须再问一个人他们想在汉堡里加什么，我就要自杀了。
Well, that was Sarah's experience. Other women have a different experience in the sex industry. Today on our program, Act One, someone whose life comes apart working in the go-go clubs. Act Two, a guy who prefers pornography to having sex with his girlfriend changes. Stay with us.
好吧，这就是莎拉的经历。其他女性在性产业中的经历则不同。今天我们的节目，第一幕，一个在舞厅工作却生活破碎的人。第二幕，一个更喜欢色情作品而不是和女朋友发生性关系的男人发生了改变。请继续收听。
Act One, Susan.
第一幕，苏珊。
Last summer, reporter and radio producer Sandy Tolan was going to do a story about the sex industry from the worker's prospective, with a woman named Susan Walsh. Walsh was an aspiring writer who worked in go-go bars in New Jersey to support her son. And then a week or so before they were going to start work on their documentary, Susan Walsh disappeared.
去年夏天，记者兼广播制作人桑迪·托兰打算以工人的视角做一个关于性产业的报道，对象是一位名叫苏珊·沃尔什的女性。沃尔什是一位有抱负的作家，在新泽西州的舞厅工作以抚养儿子。而在他们准备开始拍摄纪录片前一周左右，苏珊·沃尔什失踪了。
On July 16, she left her home in Nutley, New Jersey, to make a call at a pay phone on the corner. She didn't have a phone at home. She left her wallet, her keys, and her beeper behind. She told her son that she would be right back, and she never came back. Everybody close to her assumes that she's dead.
7月16日，她离开新泽西州纳特利的家，去街角的公用电话打了个电话。她家里没有电话。她把钱包、钥匙和传呼机都留下了。她告诉儿子她马上回来，但她再也没回来。她身边的人都认为她已经遇害了。
So Sandy Tolan decided to set out on a different story. To try to understand what her life was like in the go-go bars of Jersey. And to understand what might have led to her life coming apart.
于是桑迪·托兰决定换一个故事。试图了解她在新泽西舞厅的生活是怎样的。以及了解是什么导致了她生活的崩溃。
Again, a warning to parents, this is another story about the sex industry. Large sections of it may not be suitable for younger listeners.
再次提醒家长，这是另一个关于性产业的故事。其中大部分内容可能不适合年轻听众。
My first stop is at The Village Voice , where my old friend, James Ridgeway, works as a political correspondent. Jim had suggested Susan Walsh and I work together. She was the researcher for his new book, Red Light: Inside the Sex Industry, which tells the story from the point of view of the workers, strippers, street walkers, call girls, and porn actors.
我的第一站是《乡村之声》，我的老朋友詹姆斯·里奇韦在那里担任政治通讯员。吉姆建议我和苏珊·沃尔什合作。她是吉姆新书《红灯：性产业内幕》的研究员，这本书从舞女、站街女、应召女郎和色情演员等从业者的角度讲述了性产业的故事。
I first met Susan Walsh in the offices of Screw magazine when I was working on a book about the sex industry. And I went to see Al Goldstein, who was the editor. And as I was talking to him, I was complaining about how I couldn't get anywhere in this whole business. And asked him if he could give me some advice. And he said, well, you know, there's this woman that comes in here every so often and she writes for us and she'd be really good because she really knows this stuff.
我第一次见到苏珊·沃尔什是在《螺丝》杂志的办公室，当时我正在写一本关于性产业的书。我去见主编阿尔·戈德斯坦。我在和他交谈时，抱怨自己在这个行业里寸步难行，并请他给我一些建议。他说，好吧，你知道，有个女人经常来这里，她为我们写稿，她会非常出色，因为她真的很了解这些东西。
And at that point, for some reason, this woman suddenly appeared and she had this kind of long, blonde hair. It was kind of flying in the wind. And she had this motorcycle jacket and she's real skinny and awkward looking. She hardly looked like somebody you'd think was a striptease dancer, or go-go dancer. She looked like kind of a college kid. Only as I later learned that Susan was in her 30s.
就在那时，不知何故，这个女人突然出现了，她留着一头长长的金发。在风中飘扬。她穿着一件摩托夹克，人非常瘦，看起来有些笨拙。她看起来一点也不像你会认为的脱衣舞女或舞女。她看起来就像个大学生。直到后来我才知道，苏珊已经30多岁了。
A single mother trying to break into journalism paying the bills by dancing Jersey go-go. Susan started working with Jim, two, three days a week.
一位试图涉足新闻界的单身母亲，靠跳新泽西的舞厅舞来支付账单。苏珊开始与吉姆合作，每周两到三天。
And she was very smart. She certainly knew the sex business like nobody I ever met when I was doing this book and I certainly met quite a few people. She knew all aspects of it, and what she didn't know, she'd find out. She was like a really good reporter. And she was a terrifically good mother. The big thing in her life was her kid. Her son, David, who at that time was 10, 11.
她非常聪明。在我写这本书的过程中，我见过很多人，但她对性产业的了解无人能及。她了解这个行业的方方面面，而她不知道的，她会去查明。她是一个非常优秀的记者。而且她是一个非常称职的母亲。她生命中最重要的事情就是她的孩子。她的儿子大卫，当时10、11岁左右。
He would come to my office and he'd work on the computer. He'd work his homework while she did her work on the telephone or we talked. And she was just totally devoted to this boy.
他会来我的办公室，在电脑上工作。他在她打电话或我们交谈时做家庭作业。她对这个孩子全心全意。
Susan longed to be a full-time writer. Jim got her to write a few pieces on go-go for the Voice . He set her up with a couple of film and radio gigs, but dancing paid the bills. She'd work six days a week sometimes, two shifts a day, just barely making it.
苏珊渴望成为一名全职作家。吉姆让她为《乡村之声》写了几篇关于舞厅的文章。他给她安排了几份电影和广播的工作，但跳舞才是她的经济来源。她有时每周工作六天，一天两个班，勉强维持生计。
And she was always toting his bag around with her with her g-string and her heels. She didn't have the money to get on the PATH train to go home. She would just check into one of these clubs and dance a set. And see if she'd come out with $10. Now that's not exactly the high life here.
她总是随身带着包，里面装着丁字裤和高跟鞋。她没钱坐PATH火车回家。她就会直接进一家夜店跳上一场。看看能不能赚到10美元出来。这可不是什么奢华的生活。
At dusk, I head through the Lincoln tunnel to the Jersey Turnpike, past the big, white oil storage tanks and the rusted globes of national gas. I'm riding with Jill Morley, a writer and actress who worked in Jersey go-go until a couple of years ago when she got sick of it and left. Jill was a friend of Susan's.
黄昏时分，我穿过林肯隧道前往新泽西收费公路，经过巨大的白色储油罐和生锈的天然气球体。我和吉尔·莫利同行，她是一位作家兼演员，曾在新泽西的舞厅工作，几年前因为厌倦而离开。吉尔是苏珊的朋友。
It's terribly sad. I go in and out of being emotional about it because sometimes it just seems like it's too absurd to be true that it's happened. It just feels such a loss.
这太令人悲伤了。我的情绪起起伏伏，因为有时这一切看起来太荒谬，简直难以置信。这感觉真是一种巨大的损失。
Jersey is the land of go-go, 350 clubs by one estimate. The most of any state.
新泽西是舞厅之乡，据估计有350家夜店。是所有州中最多的。
We pull off the Turnpike and head into the small town of Belleville, just outside Newark. We're trying to find an old haunt of Susan's. And there it is right on a well lit main drag. Wiggles says the pink sign. And below that a banner, breakfast special, legs and eggs. Friday 7:00 AM to Noon.
我们驶离收费公路，进入纽瓦克郊外的小镇贝尔维尔。我们试图寻找苏珊的一处旧时常去的地方。就在那儿，在灯火通明的大街上。招牌写着“摆动”。下面还有一条横幅，“早餐特惠，美腿与鸡蛋。周五早上7点到中午”。
This seems more like a place Susan would work. It's more like divey and I don't know. More regular looking women working. You know, very Jersey looking.
这看起来更像是苏珊会工作的地方。它更像是一个下等场所，我不知道。工作的都是些看起来很普通的女性。你知道，非常有新泽西的感觉。
On the narrow linoleum bar at Wiggles, a woman walks the gauntlet between the hands of men and the bottles of whiskey, gyrating in a Spandex bikini. She pivots toward the men, pauses, presses her breasts together. A customer lodges a folded up dollar bill in her cleavage.
在“摆动”狭窄的油毡吧台上，一个穿着氨纶比基尼的女人在男人的手和威士忌酒瓶之间走过，扭动着身体。她转向男人们，停顿了一下，将双乳挤在一起。一名顾客把折叠的一美元钞票塞进她的乳沟里。
At the bar, we ask around, but nobody seems to remember much about Susan Walsh.
在吧台，我们四处打听，但似乎没人记得太多关于苏珊·沃尔什的事。
Can I ask you something? We're friends of Susan Walsh.
我可以问你一件事吗？我们是苏珊·沃尔什的朋友。
What?
什么？
Of Susan Walsh.
苏珊·沃尔什的朋友。
But then a dancer tells us, oh, yeah, she remembers Susan. She takes Jill backstage to the dressing room where it's quieter.
但随后一位舞女告诉我们，哦，是的，她记得苏珊。她带着吉尔去了安静的后台更衣室。
Oh, yeah. I met her. She was very nice. She was really, really nice. But I thought she was a little bit ditzy. And when I found out when she was missing and I read the article in the New York Times . No, the New York Post and it said that she was working on a documentary and all this stuff. I was thinking, it's terrible that she didn't seem that smart to me. Not that she wasn't smart, but she seemed a little ditzy and she didn't seem that mature. Then I found out she was 36 and I was surprised.
哦，是的。我见过她。她人很好。真的非常好。但我当时觉得她有点傻乎乎的。当我发现她失踪并读到《纽约时报》——不，是《纽约邮报》上的文章时，上面说她在做一部纪录片之类的。我在想，真糟糕，她在我看来并不那么聪明。不是说她不聪明，但她看起来有点呆头呆脑，而且看起来不太成熟。后来我发现她已经36岁了，我感到很惊讶。
Thought she looked really nice. Whenever I seen her I thought she was very striking because she was so pale skinned and her hair was so white without looking phony. Most girls with white hair, it just looks bleached, it's phony. It looked very natural on her. Whether it was real or not, I don't know.
我觉得她看起来真的很不错。每当我见到她，都觉得她很显眼，因为她皮肤那么白，而且她的头发是白色的，看起来一点也不假。大多数染白发的女孩，看起来就是漂白的，很假。在她身上看起来非常自然。是不是真的，我就不知道了。
Somebody told me that her family pretty much thinks that she must be dead because she hasn't popped up yet and she would never leave her son. And they were saying maybe they should put it on Unsolved Mysteries. Maybe they'd find her then.
有人告诉我，她的家人基本认为她肯定已经死了，因为她一直没出现，而且她绝不会离开她儿子。他们说也许应该把这事发到《未解之谜》节目上。也许那样就能找到她了。
They are. They're doing it.
他们确实在做。他们正在做这件事。
Are they going to? When is it going to be on?
他们要拍吗？什么时候播出？
February 14 I think it's supposed to air.
我想是2月14号播出。
Wow. That would be great. Maybe something will come of it.
哇。那太好了。也许会有什么结果。
Yeah, hopefully.
是的，希望如此。
And so it goes throughout the evening. Jill and I walk into a go-go bar. Jill goes backstage and dancers speculates on what might have happened to Susan. Maybe it was the Russian mob. Maybe it was the regular mob. Maybe it was a deranged go-go patron. Maybe somebody was mad at something she said in the book Red Light.
夜晚就这样过去了。吉尔和我走进一家舞厅。吉尔去后台，舞女们猜测苏珊可能发生了什么事。也许是俄罗斯黑手党干的。也许是普通黑手党。也许是一个疯狂的舞厅顾客。也许有人对她在《红灯》书中所写的内容感到愤怒。
It could have been anything.
什么都有可能。
You think she could have been bumped off maybe?
你觉得她可能是被做掉的吗？
Who knows? Who knows? But there have been quite a few dancers that have been found in different areas.
谁知道呢？谁知道呢？但在不同地区已经发现了不少舞女的尸体。
Really?
真的吗？
Of course. Yeah, you hear about it. In the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] magazine or in the newspaper. It's never played up. Because everybody thinks, a go-go dancer. Oh, she must be a slut or whatever. They're still people too, and whatever they do they do. But nobody deserves to be killed.
当然。是的，你经常听说。在杂志上或者报纸里。这些报道从来不会大肆宣扬。因为每个人都会想，不过是个舞女。哦，她肯定是个荡妇之类的。她们也依然是人，无论她们做什么。但没人应该被杀。
Here, at the Marleybone, a dancer speaks in sharp, low tones, warning us not to ask too many questions about what happened to Susan.
在这里，在马利波恩夜店，一名舞女尖锐而低沉地警告我们，不要再问关于苏珊发生了什么事的太多问题。
Here at Club After Dark, dozens of Russian women, part of the new wave of immigrant labor grind themselves into the laps of the men at the bar.
在“天黑后”俱乐部，几十名俄罗斯女性，作为新一波移民劳工的一部分，在吧台男人的大腿上磨蹭。
Here at Club 516, smoke and Spandex and dead eyes. A woman mechanically pulling her skirt up and down as she stares at herself in the mirror. I'm reminded of a photograph of Susan in the book Red Light.
在516号俱乐部，烟雾、氨纶和死寂的眼神。一个女人机械地拉起又放下裙子，盯着镜子里的自己。我想起了《红灯》书中苏珊的一张照片。
She's on a carpeted stage, guys with beards are perched on bar stools enjoying a laugh. And Susan, in a bikini, blonde hair falling over her shoulders, swivels her backside toward the men. She's poised before the mirror, dazed, alone, in another world.
她站在铺着地毯的舞台上，留着胡子的男人们坐在吧台凳上开怀大笑。而苏珊穿着比基尼，金发垂在肩上，将后背朝向男人们扭动。她站在镜子前，茫然，孤独，仿佛身处另一个世界。
Susan used to say that when she first got into go-go, it seemed like such a good idea. Her she is telling her story on a radio talk show two weeks before she disappeared.
苏珊过去常说，她刚开始做舞女时，觉得这似乎是个好主意。这是她失踪前两周在一个广播脱口秀节目中讲述自己的故事。
I had been working for six years as a writer for engineering and business publications after college and raising a son pretty much on my own. I was separated and I'd lost my job because of the recession. And I said, wow, how can I raise my son, go to graduate school, and take my writing out of the trade sector into the public sector and still do it all? Not just have time to make dinner and go to sleep every night. And I thought it was an easy way out because I had a friend who was making thousands a week. She said to me, why don't you dance a couple nights a week, and then you can do whatever you want. Raise your kid, go to school. I said, great.
大学毕业后，我做了六年的工程和商业出版物作家，几乎是一个人抚养儿子。我分居了，因为经济衰退丢了工作。我说，哇，我怎么才能抚养儿子、读研究生，并把我的写作从贸易领域带到公共领域，同时还能兼顾这一切？不仅仅是有时间做晚饭和每晚睡觉。我觉得这是一条捷径，因为我有位朋友每周赚几千美元。她对我说，你为什么不每周跳两晚舞，然后你想做什么就做什么。抚养孩子，去上学。我说，太棒了。
At first I felt totally in control. Lots of attention, men loved me. I'm getting attention. I'm the little princess on stage. It's insidious and after a while I realized that it was exhausting. There were many hidden costs and I stayed in it for far too many years and I'm not happy with the fact that I am still dancing.
起初我感觉完全在掌控之中。有很多关注，男人们爱我。我得到了关注。我是舞台上的小公主。这很阴险，一段时间后我意识到这让人精疲力竭。有很多隐形成本，我深陷其中太多年了，我不高兴自己还在跳舞。
Yes, I did complete half of my master's and I have been doing a lot of writing. But boy, what a high price I had to pay.
是的，我确实完成了硕士学位的二分之一，也做了很多写作工作。但天哪，我付出了多么高昂的代价。
At lunchtime, on the last day of July, I drive out to see Susan's mom, Martha Young, in Wayne, New Jersey. Susan's son, David, is visiting that day. Susan's been missing for two weeks now. We eat lunch and make small talk, then they invite me to join them at a video arcade at the mall.
七月最后一天午餐时间，我开车去新泽西州韦恩市见苏珊的母亲玛莎·扬。苏珊的儿子大卫那天也在。苏珊已经失踪两周了。我们吃过午饭寒暄了几句，他们邀请我一起去商场的电子游戏厅。
What do you want to do [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Should we get the tickets first?
你想做什么？我们要先去买票吗？
Oh, Lucky & Wild. That's a great two-player game.
哦，《幸运与狂野》。那是个很棒的双人游戏。
Martha watches David run off, dashing between video games. She's glad he's got something else to do besides think about his mother. She says he's blocking his feelings, not wanting to confront the possibilities.
玛莎看着大卫跑开，穿梭在电子游戏机之间。她很高兴他除了想念母亲之外还有别的事可做。她说他在封闭自己的感受，不想面对现实的可能性。
I hope Suzy is still alive, but it's the not knowing that is so horrible. But it's also what would be worse is knowing that she isn't with us anymore. I'm just crazy inside. I feel as though I'm broken apart.
我希望苏西还活着，但这种未知的状态太可怕了。更糟糕的是知道她已经不在我们身边了。我内心都要疯了。我觉得自己整个人都破碎了。
This is all so unlike Susan, her mom says. She would never leave David like this. Then Martha pauses a moment. She has something she wants to say. She stares at my microphone.
这一切太不像苏珊了，她妈妈说。她绝不会就这样丢下大卫。然后玛莎停顿了一会儿。她有话想说。她盯着我的麦克风。
Hi, Suzy, this is mom. If you're listening or if you hear about this, I want to give a message to you. I love you very, very much. More than anybody in the world. And I just want to see you again. And please, take good care of yourself wherever you are and know that you're loved and missed so much by everybody. I love you.
嗨，苏西，我是妈妈。如果你正在听或者听说这件事，我想给你留个口信。我爱你，非常非常多。比世界上任何人都多。我只是想再见你一面。无论你在哪里，请照顾好自己，要知道每个人都非常爱你和想念你。我爱你。
Late October, three and a half months now since Susan disappeared. Jill Morley and I are in Midtown, Manhattan. We're paying a visit on Susan's therapist, Mary Nolan, who works a lot with go-go girls and prostitutes. We're trying to make sense of something. By all accounts, Susan had a lot going for her outside of go-go, and she wasn't making much money dancing, yet she kept doing it.
十月下旬，苏珊失踪已经三个半月了。吉尔·莫利和我在曼哈顿中城。我们去拜访苏珊的治疗师玛丽·诺兰，她经常与舞女和妓女打交道。我们试图弄明白一件事。根据所有人的说法，苏珊在舞厅之外有很多发展的机会，而且她跳舞也赚不了多少钱，可她还是坚持做下去。
Susan could not cut the ties with that world because it was a powerful pull for her. So something was happening. I guess the term would be repetition compulsion. It's acting out some type of an early event to get it right in the future. And she worked the whole gamut of the adult sex industry. I don't think she missed a wrinkle because she had a need to know and do this. And then she had a need to write about it and tell people about it.
苏珊无法切断与那个世界的联系，因为它对她有强大的吸引力。所以肯定有什么事情在发生。我想这个术语应该是“强迫性重复”。即把某种早期的事件重演，试图在未来将其纠正。她尝试了整个成人性产业的全部范围。我认为她没有错过任何环节，因为她有一种去了解和尝试的需要。然后她又有一种把这些写下来并告诉人们的需要。
And now a striptease from the beautiful Susan Walsh for you out there in Midnight Blue land.
现在，美丽的苏珊·沃尔什为你献上一段脱衣舞。
Hi, I'm Susan Walsh and I'm a dancer. This is what I do for you when I dance in gentlemen's clubs. I move as if I were your lover, some fantastic embodiment of [? veloxed ?] beauty, breathless, hungry siren--
嗨，我是苏珊·沃尔什，我是一名舞者。当我在绅士俱乐部跳舞时，我为你做这些。我的动作仿佛我是你的情人，是某种奇幻美的化身，令人窒息的、饥渴的海妖——
Susan wrote this essay for Al Goldstein's Midnight Blue porn cable show. And defending the notion of free speech, they put it on.
苏珊为阿尔·戈德斯坦的“午夜蓝”色情有线电视节目写了这篇文章。为了捍卫言论自由，他们播出了。
Now I will be [UNINTELLIGIBLE] for you. You say you will, you must tease my sexual nerves.
现在我要为你……你说是你要的，你必须挑逗我的性神经。
You laugh when I  struggle to protect my nipples from your raggedy fingers, as if I'm trying to believe the absurd notion that I'm real.
当你用粗糙的手指试图去碰我的乳头时，你笑了，就好像我试图相信自己是真实的这一荒谬想法一样。
She smiles, takes off her top, calls the bar patrons, "Pathetic droplets of insect mucus."
她微笑着脱掉上衣，称吧台顾客为“可悲的昆虫粘液滴”。
We count the dollar bills you stuff into our costumes or fold into nauseatingly cute shapes like frogs or flowers. We unravel it all at the end of the night, our legs coated with dust and bruises and memories of your existence rush from our mind.
我们数着你塞进我们服装里的钞票，或者折成恶心可爱的青蛙或花朵形状。我们在深夜解开这一切，我们的腿上沾满灰尘、淤青和对你存在的记忆，这些从我们的脑海中飞逝。
If we thought about you too long, we'd go crazy. So we stuff your bills in our pockets, just like we stuff the idea that maybe we all lost out. Maybe paying the rent just isn't worth--
如果我们长时间想你，我们会疯掉的。所以我们把你的钞票塞进兜里，就像我们塞住那个想法：也许我们全都输了。也许付房租根本不值得——
Christmastime now, I'm back in New York. It's more than five months since anyone's heard a word from Susan. Susan's father, Floyd Merchant, drives in from New Jersey to see me. He looks like he's been crying. He says he often talked to Susan about quitting go-go.
现在是圣诞节，我回到纽约。距离大家听到苏珊的消息已经过去五个多月了。苏珊的父亲弗洛伊德·麦钱特从新泽西开车来见我。他看起来像是哭过。他说他经常劝苏珊退出舞厅。
The go-go bars were the worst place for somebody with their head on straight. Her's wasn't on straight. First of all, she's a recovering alcoholic and drug addict and is sitting on the railroad tracks jumping off every time the train passes. And then jumping right back on. I thought she might have cardiac arrest. I was almost sure she was going to go back to drinking and using.
对于头脑清醒的人来说，舞厅是最糟糕的地方。而她的头脑并不清醒。首先，她是一个正在康复的酗酒者和吸毒者，却坐在铁轨上，每次火车经过就跳开。然后又跳回去。我以为她会心脏病发作。我几乎确定她会回去喝酒和吸毒。
Susan's health was failing. She had emphysema, an ulcer, and chronic bronchitis. And then she did start drinking and using drugs again, mixing them with the anti-anxiety drug, Xanax. It was a potent cocktail and Susan started getting more and more disconnected from reality.
苏珊的健康状况在恶化。她患有肺气肿、溃疡和慢性支气管炎。然后她确实又开始喝酒和吸毒，还将它们与抗焦虑药物阿普唑仑混合使用。这是一个强效的组合，苏珊开始越来越与现实脱节。
She was already living in a fantasy world, in a paranoid fantasy world. Not a happy fantasy world. She was running to people saying, there's a contract out on me, but don't tell anybody. Then she'd run to somebody else and say, there's a contract out on me, but don't tell anybody. And this is a preliminary to a real breakdown.
她已经生活在一个幻想世界里，一个偏执的幻想世界里。不是快乐的幻想世界。她跑到人们面前说，有人给我下了合同，但别告诉任何人。然后她又跑到另一个人面前说，有人给我下了合同，但别告诉任何人。这是精神崩溃的前兆。
She was addicted to the fantasy part of her life. A lot of the people that she associated with from the bars and stuff like that, they played the fantasy of FBI and CIA.
她沉迷于她生活中的幻想部分。她从夜店结识的许多人，都扮演着FBI和CIA的幻想游戏。
Now we're back in Jersey, Newark, on a windy, bitter December day. Jill and I are visiting Melissa Hines, Susan's best friend.
现在我们回到了新泽西，纽瓦克，在一个风大刺骨的十二月天。吉尔和我去拜访苏珊最好的朋友梅丽莎·海因斯。
She had a friend that claimed that he belonged to the CIA. He was playing the role that she wanted to hear. Oh, I'm CIA. I'm going to Washington for the weekend. Oh, I'm working undercover against the mafia. So it was like this big role playing stuff that I think she lived for that fantasy and the danger that she thought she was in. It was crazy.
她有个朋友声称他属于CIA。他扮演着她想听的角色。哦，我是CIA。我周末要去华盛顿。哦，我正在执行针对黑手党的卧底任务。所以就像是某种大型角色扮演，我认为她为那种幻想和她自以为身处的危险而活。太疯狂了。
And what did the guy turn out to be?
那个家伙后来被发现是什么人？
He turned out to be-- worked for a trucking company.
他被发现是……在一家货运公司工作。
But lot of the fantasy world that she lived in, I think it had a lot to do with the fact that she was once diagnosed with bipolar disorder, manic depressiveness, and she wasn't taking her medication. So she needed a lot of help.
但她所生活的幻想世界，我认为这和她曾经被诊断患有双相情感障碍、躁郁症有很大关系，而且她没有吃药。所以她需要很多帮助。
Dozens of presents are piled up under Melissa's Christmas tree, most for her nine-month-old boy. Melissa's having a hard time talking to us. She and Susan used to celebrate Christmas together, and Susan was there when the baby was born.
梅丽莎的圣诞树下堆满了礼物，大部分是给她九个月大的儿子的。梅丽莎很难跟我们交谈。她和苏珊过去常一起庆祝圣诞节，苏珊在她孩子出生时也在场。
Melissa gets up, turns on a light, retrieves a well-worn folder. Like everyone in Susan's life, Melissa's been trying to figure out what happened.
梅丽莎起身，打开灯，取出一个磨损的文件夹。像苏珊生命中的每个人一样，梅丽莎一直试图弄清楚发生了什么。
This is stuff that I wrote down.
这是我写下来的东西。
What is it?
是什么？
It's different people that'd seen her. I wrote down who was calling her. Who she was associating with. She was around a lot of different people. I mean, Friday, July 12, Susan went to Towne Tap in Irvington and was sick. I was at her house and I talked to her and I left. That was the last time I'd seen her, was July 12.
是不同见到她的人。我写下了谁在给她打电话。她和谁在一起。她身边有很多不同的人。我的意思是，7月12日星期五，苏珊去了欧文顿的Towne Tap，当时她病了。我在她家，我和她谈过话然后离开了。那是最后一次见到她，是在7月12日。
July 13, Susan worked at the Showplace from 5:30 at night to 1:45 AM.
7月13日，苏珊在表演场所工作，从晚上5点半到凌晨1点45分。
On July 16, Susan left her house around noon. By 3:30, Melissa had a strange feeling. She hurried over to Susan's.
7月16日，苏珊中午左右离开家。到3点半，梅丽莎有了一种奇怪的感觉。她匆忙赶到苏珊家。
I rung the bell and it looked like there was nobody there and nobody answered. And I got a very bad feeling. Just emptiness inside.
我按了门铃，看起来里面没人，也没人回应。我有一种非常糟糕的感觉。内心只有空虚。
At first, everyone had a hunch. Susan had been murdered by a stalker. Susan had been kidnapped and sold to a motorcycle gang. Susan had been abducted by the Russian mob for sniffing around the story she and I were going to do. Susan was a streetwalker in Newark. She was a call girl in Elizabeth. A dancer in a nightclub upstate or she'd fallen in with a vampire cult. Or she'd checked herself into rehab. Or she enrolled in the witness protection plan. Or she'd died of a drug overdose. As time has passed, more and more of her friends, family, and coworkers have come to believe Susan Walsh is dead.
起初，每个人都有预感。苏珊被一个跟踪狂谋杀了。苏珊被绑架并卖给了摩托车帮。苏珊因为调查我们打算做的那个故事而被俄罗斯黑手党绑架了。苏珊是纽瓦克的站街女。她是伊丽莎白的应召女郎。是州北部的舞厅舞女，或者她陷入了一个吸血鬼邪教。或者她自己进了康复中心。或者她加入了证人保护计划。或者她吸毒过量死亡了。随着时间的推移，越来越多的朋友、家人和同事开始相信苏珊·沃尔什已经死了。
Which Which house? Is it the one with the rolling Christmas lights?
哪一栋房子？是挂着滚动圣诞灯的那一栋吗？
No, I think it's this one.
不，我想是这一栋。
Wait, let me just make sure.
等一下，让我确认一下。
January. We look up a guy who says he thinks he knows what happened. He worked with Susan in the business. The guy says he'll talk on a couple of conditions. If we don't use his name, if we distort his voice, and if he talks just to Jill, not to me. She worked go-go, he feels she understands the life. Plus he clearly prefers the idea of a woman visiting him. I wait in the car.
一月。我们找了一个声称他认为自己知道发生了什么事的家伙。他曾在这个行业和苏珊一起工作。这人说他会在几个条件下谈话。如果我们不用他的名字，如果我们对他的声音做变声处理，而且如果他只对吉尔谈，而不是对我。她做过舞厅，他觉得她懂这个生活。再说他显然更喜欢女性来访。我在车里等。
OK. I'm a little nervous. Some dog's barking. Oh boy.
好的。我有点紧张。有只狗在叫。哦，天哪。
Hey puppy. Man, it is cold out.
嘿，小狗。天哪，外面真冷。
Star fleet command is waiting for my official report. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
星际舰队指挥部正在等待我的正式报告。[听不清短语]。
Can I offer you a drink, like alcohol, wine? Gin and tonic? Anything like that?
我可以给你倒杯酒吗，比如酒精，葡萄酒？金汤力？类似这种东西？
Here's what Jill reports from the interview. He lives with his invalid mother. Copies of Mentertainment, the guide to Jersey go-go, are scattered on the table. Nailed into the wall there's a whip broken in half. In his spare time, the guy makes knives. he keeps a photo album, Polaroids of his go-go girls to help him book clubs. He has 80 dancers working all over Jersey. He drives them to and from their gigs.
这就是吉尔从采访中汇报的情况。他和残疾的母亲住在一起。桌上散落着《娱乐》，新泽西舞厅指南。墙上钉着一根折断的鞭子。闲暇时，这家伙制造刀具。他保存着相册，那些他旗下舞女的拍立得照片，方便他联系夜店。他在新泽西各地有80名舞女在工作。他负责接送她们去工作。
You're your own boss. It's your car. You can tell them to drink, smoke, or not. I constantly having girls say, well, can I smoke in here? And I'm like, yeah. No problem. But I got a little bit of the power there. I could tell them, no, suffer. Let's see you go through a nicotine fit for the next half hour. I'm sadistic.
你是你自己的老板。这是你的车。你可以告诉她们可以喝酒、抽烟或者不行。经常有女孩说，好吧，我可以在这里抽烟吗？我就像，好吧。没问题。但我有一点权力在那里。我可以告诉她们，不，忍着。让我们看看你接下来半小时怎么应对尼古丁戒断反应。我是个虐待狂。
I guess so.
我想是吧。
During the interview, the guy won't look Jill in the eyes. He turns on the TV, puts it on mute, stares at it. He puffs on his pipe, lighting it over and over.
采访期间，这家伙不看吉尔的眼睛。他打开电视，静音，盯着屏幕。他抽着烟斗，一遍又一遍地点燃。
Let me ask you some more stuff about Susan. What kind of person was she?
让我再问你一些关于苏珊的事情。她是什么样的人？
She is your typical, average dancer. If there was rap music on, she could dance to that. If it was rock and roll, she could dance to that. It didn't matter, she was good about the whole thing.
她是你典型的、普通的舞女。如果放的是说唱音乐，她就能跳那个。如果是摇滚乐，她也能跳。没关系，她做得很不错。
For somebody who was 36 and danced, I'd say she was in very good shape. She wasn't untoned or anything like that. She was pretty tight. The only thing she didn't have was a tan.
对于一个36岁还在跳舞的人来说，我会说她状态非常好。她并不松垮或者类似的情况。她相当紧致。唯一没有的就是晒黑。
What do you think happened to her?
你认为她发生了什么？
I think she fell in some sort of a fatal attraction who made her just that. And she got into somebody's car that she knew and drove away with him and never came back.
我想她陷入了某种致命吸引，让她变成了那样。她上了某个她认识的人的车，然后和他一起离开了，就再也没回来。
What makes you think that, that it was a fatal attraction thing? Had you heard about this happening?
是什么让你觉得是致命吸引的事？你听说过这种事吗？
Yeah, she had spoke to me within the prior two weeks to this and said how somebody was constantly beeping her. Susan can just be so friendly, so nice and naive. Maybe she didn't realize what kind of person this actually is.
是的，她在出事前两周内曾跟我提起过，有人不断地给她的传呼机发信息。苏珊有时太友善、太好、太天真了。也许她没意识到这到底是个什么样的人。
It's not clear how much this go-go driver really knows, but Susan did tell people she had a stalker. She told me the week before she disappeared. She told Melissa. She told the therapist. And during a shoot for a documentary Jill's producing, she told a group of other dancers, two days before she disappeared.
目前还不清楚这个舞厅司机到底知道多少，但苏珊确实告诉过别人她有个跟踪狂。她在失踪前一周告诉了我。她告诉了梅丽莎。她告诉了治疗师。而且在吉尔制作的一部纪录片拍摄过程中，她在失踪前两天告诉了一群其他舞女。
That's my beeper. It's probably a stalker right now. I do have a stalker.
那是我的传呼机。现在可能就是跟踪狂。我确实有一个跟踪狂。
You You have a stalker?
你……你有一个跟踪狂？
I have a stalker too.
我也有一个跟踪狂。
I have a stalker. I usually have stalkers.
我有一个跟踪狂。我通常都有跟踪狂。
It could have been Susan's paranoia talking. Most of the people who knew her well believe she died of a drug overdose and whoever was with the panicked and disposed of the body. And the Nutley, New Jersey, police say they checked out the stalker theory. They say they twice hauled in a guy and determined he had nothing to do with Susan's disappearance. But the cops, themselves, were slow in getting started. A week or so after Susan vanished, I called them to see what they knew. A detective told me, well, she's, you know, a dancer. She's probably out, you know, partying.
这可能是苏珊的偏执妄想在作祟。大多数了解她的人认为她死于吸毒过量，而无论当时和谁在一起，那个人都惊慌失措并处理了尸体。新泽西州纳特利的警察说他们调查了跟踪狂理论。他们说他们两次传唤了一个家伙，确定他和苏珊的失踪无关。但警察自己起步很慢。苏珊失踪一周左右后，我打电话给他们看看他们知道什么。一位侦探告诉我，嗯，她，你知道，是个舞女。她可能出去，你知道，狂欢去了。
Eventually several of us pointed out Susan was also a journalist on assignment. Within days, they'd begun a major investigation.
最终，我们中有几个人指出苏珊也是一位正在执行任务的记者。几天之内，他们就开始了一项重大调查。
Yeah, we wanted to see Detective Ryan. I'm Sandy Tolan. He's expecting us.
是的，我们想见瑞安侦探。我是桑迪·托兰。他在等我们。
Jill and I finally got to talk to the cops in December. But before we could ask them any questions, they made a big point of showing us how much work they'd done. Hundreds of hours, three loose leaf binders filled up with information on the case.
吉尔和我终于在十二月和警察谈上了。但在我们能问他们任何问题之前，他们特意向我们展示了他们做了多少工作。数百小时，三个装满案件信息的活页夹。
We sat down at a small round table with detectives Johnson and Ferraro. On the walls, framed posters from cop movies-- Out for Justice , One Good Cop. Detective Ferraro delivers the official line, "Nutley police believe Susan Walsh is still alive."
我们和约翰逊及法拉罗侦探坐在一张圆桌旁。墙上挂着警匪片的剧照——《正义》，《好警察》。法拉罗侦探给出了官方说法：“纳特利警方认为苏珊·沃尔什还活着。”
It's just that she's chosen not to come home at this time. We don't have any other reasons to feel that through all the interviews that we've taken and statements that we've taken and people that we've talked to don't really have any concrete evidence to show something has happened to her.
只是她目前选择不回家。通过我们所做的所有采访和陈述，以及我们谈话过的人，我们没有任何其他理由感到她已经发生了什么，没有具体证据。
Nutley police say they've checked out many reports of people who claim they saw Susan street walking in Newark, dancing go-go in North Jersey or New York. But nothing checked out.
纳特利警方说他们核实了许多关于人们声称看到苏珊在纽瓦克站街、在新泽西北部或纽约跳舞的报告。但没有一条核实是真的。
Every lead dead-ended. There was just nothing else to go on.
每条线索都是死胡同。根本没有其他进展。
And so the investigation petered out. Then in February, hopes rose again as Susan made prime time.
于是调查陷入了停滞。然后在二月，苏珊登上了黄金时段，希望再次燃起。
Tonight on Unsolved Mysteries .
今晚《未解之谜》。
Susan Walsh was a woman who lived on the edge, a stripper turned journalist whose chosen assignments plunged her into a hazardous stew of Russian mobsters and self-proclaimed vampires. In the end, however, Susan Walsh's walk on the wild side may have led to her death.
苏珊·沃尔什是一个生活在边缘的女人，一个脱衣舞女转行的记者，她选择的采访任务使她陷入了由俄罗斯黑帮和自称吸血鬼的人组成的危险泥潭。然而最终，苏珊·沃尔什在狂野一面的漫步可能导致了她的死亡。
It was another false hope producing few new leads. Months before, Jim Ridgeway and I had watched them film part of the docudrama. It was in Tower Books where Jim and Susan had done a book signing for Red Light.
这是另一个虚假的希望，几乎没产生什么新线索。几个月前，吉姆·里奇韦和我在塔图书店看他们拍摄部分纪实剧。那是吉姆和苏珊为《红灯》举行签售会的地方。
Now, the Unsolved Mysteries crew was shooting a reenactment.
现在，《未解之谜》剧组正在拍摄重演。
Very quite please. This is rehearsal.
请保持安静。这是彩排。
Up on the mezzanine there's wine, cheese, cameras, klieg lights, and actors playing the parts of Jim and Susan. Suddenly, the director spots the real Jim.
二楼有酒、奶酪、摄像机、强力射灯，还有扮演吉姆和苏珊的演员。突然，导演发现了真正的吉姆。
Hey, we got an impostor here. Get him out of here.
嘿，我们这儿有个冒牌货。让他出去。
Hey, how you doing.
嘿，你好吗。
What are you doing, you communist. Get over here. Get over to that corner. I'm serious. Come here. I can't have you in the shot. Come here.
你在干什么，你这个共产主义者。到这儿来。去那个角落。我是认真的。过来。我不能让你在镜头里。过来。
We stand in the corner, looking out at actors who look disturbingly like the real Jim Ridgeway-- tall, greying, paternal. And the real Susan Walsh-- slight, blond, vibrant.
我们站在角落里，看着那些长得令人不安地像真正的吉姆·里奇韦——高大、灰发、慈祥——以及真正的苏珊·沃尔什——苗条、金发、充满活力——的演员。
Step back please.
请退后。
Move your lights.
移开你们的灯。
OK, this is picture. Everyone this is picture. Stand by. Roll sound. We're rolling.
好，这是画面。大家注意这是画面。准备。录音。开始录制。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Take one. Mark.
[听不清]。第一条。打板。
And action.
开始。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Hi. You came out again for us--
[听不清]。嗨。你又为我们出来了——
The fake Susan makes small talk, signing copies of Red Light while the fake Jim stands by. I point to the fake Jim's larger belly and make a face. Ridgeway obliges with a sour grin, but he's looking past me, gazing at the image of a woman he worked with for three years, alive again for a moment.
冒牌苏珊在寒暄，在签售《红灯》的同时，冒牌吉姆站在一边。我指着冒牌吉姆更突出的肚子，做了个鬼脸。里奇韦配合地露出苦笑，但他看向我身后，凝视着一个他合作了三年的女人的图像，她仿佛又活了过来。
And cut.
卡。
And cut. That's a cut. Back to one everyone, please. Back to one. Thank you
卡。卡了。大家回到位置，拜托。回到位置。谢谢。
I've stayed in it so long that my health is so bad. I have emphysema, bronchitis, and an ulcer.
我干太久了，导致身体很差。我有肺气肿、支气管炎和溃疡。
Geez.
天哪。
Yeah, and I was in the hospital twice in the last two weeks.
是的，过去两周我进了两次医院。
This is the real Susan in the documentary shoot with Jill and the other dancers. It was two days before she disappeared and it was like Susan was watching herself go down.
这是真正的苏珊在吉尔和舞女们的纪录片拍摄现场。那是在她失踪前两天，感觉就像苏珊在看着自己一步步坠落。
I just went through the same thing.
我刚刚经历了一样的事情。
I'm just trying to hang onto my raison d'etre, my reason for being at this point. I'm just trying to hang on. But I stayed in so long that it got me. Because you can crawl on stage half dead. But I stayed in it so long. If you stay in it so long, it will break down your health to the point where you just can't go out and get the job. Now if I had a month to rest, get my health back. But I can't because I'm the only one supporting my son, so I can't stop. And yet, staying in it is killing me. So I'm sort of scared right now.
我只是试着抓住我的生存理由，在这个阶段我存在的原因。我只是试着坚持下去。但我坚持太久了，它毁了我。因为你可以半死不活地爬上舞台。但我坚持太久了。如果你坚持太久，它会摧毁你的健康，直到你无法出去找工作。现在如果我有一个月的时间休息，恢复健康。但我不能，因为我是唯一支撑我儿子的人，所以我不能停。然而，坚持做这个正在杀死我。所以我现在有点害怕。
A Sunday morning and I'm going back home to Boston. I drop over to say goodbye to Jill.
周日早上，我回波士顿的家。我顺便去和吉尔告别。
Susan is an extension of all the dancers, all of us. And so what happened to her is that typical dancer trap of going all the way down this downward spiral and choosing the darkest path. She chose the darkest path that we all see. We can see that path and yet, she took it. And it's possible that I could've taken it, or that any one of these other girls could have taken it. And that's really terrifying. And especially that's she's this really smart, warm, loving, mother. Funny. And even her, even she went down that path. I mean, she was an incredible human being.
苏珊是所有舞女的延伸，我们所有人。所以发生在苏珊身上的事，是典型的舞女陷阱，一路坠落，选择最黑暗的道路。她选择了我们都能看到的黑暗道路。我们可以看到那条路，然而，她走了进去。我也有可能走上那条路，或者这些女孩中的任何一个都可能走上那条路。这真的很可怕。尤其是她还是个如此聪明、温暖、有爱、称职的母亲。有趣。即使是她，连她也走上了那条路。我的意思是，她是个不可思议的人。
Coming up, another woman and a porn customer who changes, in a minute when our program continues.
接下来，另一个女人和一个色情作品顾客改变的故事，片刻后继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, documentary producers, and performers to take a whack at that theme. Today's program, Three Women and the Sex Industry. We are at Act Two of our program, Striptease.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、纪录片制作人和表演者来围绕这个主题发挥。今天的节目，三个女人与性产业。我们进入节目的第二幕，脱衣舞。
It's easy to imagine the guy in this next story as one of the customers in a go-go bar in Northern Jersey. He's an extreme case though, and he changes.
很容易想象下一个故事里的家伙是新泽西北部舞厅里的顾客之一。不过，他是一个极端情况，而且他改变了。
Lauren Slater is a psychologist and writer in Boston. This is an account of one of her cases. Again, a warning to listeners. Some of this story may not be appropriate for younger children.
劳伦·斯莱特是波士顿的一位心理学家和作家。这是她经手的一个案例。再次提醒听众。这个故事中的一些内容可能不适合年幼的孩子。
George came to our clinic in early autumn and was diagnosed by the intake worker with an antisocial personality disorder. A sociopath, a deviant, whom I, a newcomer to the field of psychology, was now assigned to work with in therapy for an undefined period of time.
乔治在初秋来到我们的诊所，被评估员诊断为反社会人格障碍。一个社会病态者，一个异类，而我，这个心理学领域的新手，被指派在治疗中接待他一段不明确的时间。
He looked almost ridiculously tough, sitting in a sleeveless leather vest in the clinic's lobby. Hair scrunched back in a pony tail, a cigarette dangling from his mouth. Tattoos coiled over his arms. Immediately I felt awkward in his presence.
他坐在诊所大厅里，穿着无袖皮背心，看起来极其强悍。头发扎成马尾辫，嘴里叼着烟。纹身缠绕着他的手臂。我立刻感到在他面前很不自在。
The day I met George I was wearing my working garb, a sun dress, a pair of falling apart flats, legs stubbly from hair I'd only half shaved and perhaps a swatch of slip showing beneath my hem. I felt stout and dumpy.
见到乔治的那天，我穿着我的工作服，一件太阳裙，一双破旧的平底鞋，腿上长着只刮了一半的毛茬，裙摆下或许还露出了一截衬裙。我感觉自己又胖又笨。
As a therapist, I think I should be beyond these silly social embarrassments. I think I should at least be beyond my own bodily insecurities enough to throw my full attention into the client's waiting lap. But I'm not. Around George I'm not. And the sense of shame he evokes in me to this day is part of our treatment story together.
作为治疗师，我认为我应该超越这些愚蠢的社交尴尬。我认为我至少应该超越对自己身体的不安全感，从而全神贯注于客户的膝盖。但我没有。在乔治面前，我没有。他唤起我的羞耻感至今仍是我们共同治疗故事的一部分。
My office at the time was windowless, and so small we had to sit with our knees near brushing. I got ready to ask my usual orienting questions. Age?, I asked.
我当时的办公室没有窗户，小到我们不得不膝盖几乎碰到一起。我准备问我惯常的定向问题。年龄？我问。
Instead of answering me, George gave a dramatic sigh. "I have been waiting for this day," he said. "Ive seen six of you guys and so far no one's worked out. I need a doc who can really push me. I need to be challenged."
乔治没有回答，而是戏剧性地叹了口气。“我一直在等这一天，”他说。“我见过你们六个人了，目前为止还没人能行。我需要一个真正能推动我的医生。我需要被挑战。”
"Challenged?" I asked. "Like how?"
“挑战？”我问。“像怎么挑战？”
"Ive got my problems," George said, "And I can admit to them. The other six I went to just sat there and stared at me. I want someone who will give me feedback, make me see things in a new way."
“我有我的问题，”乔治说，“我能承认它们。之前的六个医生只会坐在那儿盯着我。我想要一个能给我反馈，让我以新方式看待事物的人。”
"So what are these problems?"
“那么这些问题是什么？”
George sat back, ran one hand over a large tattoo on his bicep. "Masturbation," he said gravely. "I can't stop. Can't. Seven, eight, nine times a day. I have a strong drive."
乔治坐了回去，一只手抚摸着二头肌上的大纹身。“手淫，”他严肃地说。“我停不下来。没法停。一天七、八、九次。我的驱动力很强。”
Now he pulled a list out of his pocket and began to read. "Masturbation, pornography, aggression, defensiveness, pride, control, these are my problems. Take porn. I love it, but the truth is I'd rather do it with a videotape than with my girlfriend, Joanne. We have huge beefs. Huge," George said. "My anger is just--" he paused. "Like I think I could kill her. I've killed a few people before, so I wouldn't put it past me."
现在他从口袋里掏出一张清单开始读。“手淫、色情作品、攻击性、防御性、骄傲、控制，这些就是我的问题。拿色情作品来说。我喜欢它，但事实是，我宁愿和录像带做，也不愿和我的女朋友乔安娜做。我们有巨大的矛盾。巨大，”乔治说。“我的愤怒只是……”他停顿了一下。“我觉得我可能会杀了她。我以前杀过几个人，所以我不会排除这种可能性。”
George was staring straight at me when he said this, testing me for my reaction.
乔治说这话时直视着我，在测试我的反应。
"So why do you think you prefer porn to people?" I said, keeping my voice even despite the fact that I suddenly felt like fleeing.
“那你为什么觉得你更喜欢色情作品而不是人呢？”我说，声音保持平稳，尽管我突然感觉想逃跑。
"Don't get me wrong," George said. "I like Joanne, she's a real smoker. But I'll be honest, a picture's just a lot easier. Just a completely quiet and beautiful bod."
“别误会我，”乔治说。“我喜欢乔安娜，她很性感。但我实话实说，照片要简单得多。完全安静而美丽的身体。”
I thought of my own bod then and felt my breasts beneath my dress burn with shame.
我想到了我自己的身体，感到裙子下的乳房因为羞耻而灼热。
George is 35 years old and has lived seven of those years on the street, drugging, knife fighting, and stealing. He has been clean now for half a decade, a really remarkable achievement which he attributes to his spirituality, a weird blend of mysticism and heavy metal.
乔治35岁，在街头生活了七年，吸毒、持刀斗殴、偷窃。他现在已经戒掉五年了，这是一个了不起的成就，他将其归功于他的灵性，一种神秘主义和重金属音乐的怪异融合。
In his apartment where he lived with Joanne, he has two special cupboards side by side. In one of them, he keeps his incense and tarot cards. In the other, he stores his collection of sadomasochistic videos and magazines. Oddly, this second cupboard is lined with floral contact paper left by a previous tenant.
在他和乔安娜居住的公寓里，他有两个并排的特殊柜子。其中一个装着他的香和塔罗牌。另一个柜子里存放着他的施虐受虐录像带和杂志收藏。奇怪的是，第二个柜子里贴着前任租客留下的花卉贴纸。
They bring him satisfaction, these videos. A lot goes on for him each day. Joanne is, as he said, a beautiful woman, but she is also unpredictable and self-absorbed, a series of seismic cycles he cannot control.
这些录像带给他带来满足感。他每天都要面对很多事情。乔安娜，如他所说，是一个美丽的女人，但她也反复无常、自私自利，是一连串他无法控制的地震周期。
He tells me he is from the old school, expects his woman to cook and clean, to have fish on the table by six, dustless halls, and sex where her moans are synchronized to his.
他告诉我他是老派的人，希望他的女人做饭、打扫，六点前把鱼端上桌，走廊一尘不染，性生活时她的呻吟要与他的节奏同步。
When Joanne lets him down, he gets mad. Really red-faced furious so that he hauls her up against a wall, wallops her across the face. He feels so much sheer and irrational hate that he has to retreat to his room to watch his videos. They soothe him, images of female flesh controlled.
当乔安娜让他失望时，他会生气。气到满脸通红，把她推到墙上，扇她的脸。他感到一种纯粹而无理的仇恨，必须躲回房间看录像带。那些画面让他平静：对女性肉体的控制。
In our first several sessions, I tried to find the origins of his hate. For instance, George's father beat him, but the beatings were not as bad as the humiliation that went along with them. He remembers the strap, the hands that were like hatchets. But the intensity of his tale lies for me in this image, a small boy pressed against a refrigerator, white as a nuptial bed sheet. The man pressing against him, shouting at him. George could feel his father's groin hot and hard right in the nook between his thighs. He started to think of himself as having a nook there, a gross, gaping place.
在前几次会谈中，我试图找到他仇恨的根源。例如，乔治的父亲打他，但殴打本身不如随之而来的羞辱可怕。他记得鞭带，记得像斧头一样的手。但他的故事最让我震撼的是这个画面：一个小男孩被按在冰箱上，脸色像新婚床单一样白。那个男人压着他，对他大吼。乔治能感觉到父亲的生殖器在他大腿根部滚烫而坚硬。他开始认为自己在那儿有一个凹槽，一个粗俗、张开的地方。
He imagined his body was a girl's. George was disgusted, horrified. Soon afterward, he learned to fight, started to lift weights, running from the softness that is the requisite of all rapes.
他想象自己的身体是一个女孩的。乔治感到恶心、恐惧。不久之后，他学会了打架，开始举重，逃避那柔软的、所有强奸所必需的东西。
I had, at first, a hard time dealing with George because he offended me. I understood his pornography obsession as a deflection of his own anxieties. So he wouldn't have to feel his fear, his memories of helplessness, he tried to control women.
起初，我很难应对乔治，因为他冒犯了我。我理解他对手淫的痴迷是他焦虑的转移。为了不用去感受恐惧和无助的记忆，他试图控制女性。
Now understand, I am a woman who has spent much time aiming to please men. I am a woman who, in her adolescent days, denied herself food or threw it all up so I could fit into the airless image, this man in my office was both struggling to possess and shed at the same time.
现在你要明白，我是一个花了很多时间试图讨好男人的女人。我是一个在青春期拒绝进食或全部吐掉，以便适应那种窒息形象的女人，办公室里的这个男人同时在努力占有并摆脱这个形象。
I remember the smell of myself as an anorexic, a frail, dry odor like scorched grass. My limbs coated with hair. Because of these memories, it was impossible for me to like George. But I did feel deeply for him. After all, hadn't I once driven for his same goals? To eradicate the weak part of the self who hurts and bleeds and feeds.
我记得自己厌食时的味道，一种像烧焦草地的干枯、脆弱的气味。我的四肢覆盖着毛发。因为这些记忆，我不可能喜欢乔治。但我深深地同情他。毕竟，我不是曾经也为了他的目标而努力吗？根除自我中那个会受伤、流血和进食的软弱部分。
During the first few weeks of our therapy together, I began to feel the old shame about my body returning more strongly than it had in a while. Although George said he wanted help to overcome his pornography obsession, he was sometimes driven to watch five, six films a night. And to learn to diffuse his rages, he used his sessions to vent about Joanne's latest transgressions. And from there, he would segue into diatribes about the perfect female sex organs, their size and smell.
在我们治疗的前几周，我开始感到对自己身体的那种旧的羞耻感比以往任何时候都强烈地回归。虽然乔治说他想要克服色情作品的痴迷，但他有时被迫每晚看五、六部电影。为了学会化解愤怒，他利用治疗时间来发泄乔安娜的种种过错。从那里，他会转入关于完美女性性器官的谩骂，谈论它们的大小和气味。
After a day during which I'd seen George had ended, I would go home and feel my flash more heavily than ever. I often felt like weeping. And it was during this time that I noticed small black hairs growing up around my nipples. On the one hand, I wanted to pluck them out. On the other hand, I wanted them to grow, lush like the marsh weed that springs up in swamps.
在我见到乔治的一天结束后，我回到家，感到那股羞耻感比以往任何时候都沉重。我经常想哭。也就是在这段时间，我注意到我的乳头周围长出了细小的黑毛。一方面，我想拔掉它们。另一方面，我想让它们生长，像沼泽中长出的草一样茂盛。
My prescription was for George to learn, somehow, that being soft does not mean being molested or murdered, necessarily. He would have none of it, of course.
我的处方是让乔治以某种方式明白，柔软并不一定意味着被骚扰或谋杀。当然，他根本听不进去。
We have been going at it for about two months and he told me a story that bowled me over. The woods of his childhood home divided his family's house from Teddy Swayze's, a classmate who lived through several stands of pines.
我们已经进行了大约两个月，他给我讲了一个让我震撼的故事。他童年住所的树林将他家的房子和泰迪·斯韦兹的房子隔开，那是他的一位同学，住处穿过几片松树林。
George was nine years old and that day, Teddy had promised him the use of his new red Tonka toy truck if only George would come over and play. But when he got there, Teddy went back on his part of the bargain. The truck, nope, was not to be shared.
乔治九岁时，那天泰迪承诺如果他能过来玩，就把他新的红色Tonka玩具卡车给他玩。但当他过去后，泰迪没信守承诺。那辆卡车，不行，不能共享。
George had walked all this way, had stumbled over tree roots, had opened himself to hope, only to find he was fooled. So he went home, took his father's knife, some rope from the cellar and made a gallows in the woods using branches as a platform.
乔治走这么远，跨过树根，敞开心扉去期待，却发现被耍了。所以他回家拿了父亲的刀，从地窖里弄了些绳子，用树枝作为平台在树林里做了一个绞刑架。
"Boy, have I got the coolest thing to show you," George said to Teddy. "You got to come."
“嘿，我有最酷的东西给你看，”乔治对泰迪说。“你必须过来。”
And then when they were there, George said, "Look up." It was floating against the sky, the noose, very bright in the sunlight.
当他们到那里时，乔治说，“往上看。”它悬浮在天空中，那个绞索，在阳光下非常明亮。
"Climb," George said, using the knife to persuade. He used the blade on the kid's soft skin and had a sudden jarring image of his mother in the kitchen in the morning wearing an apron and slicing through a warm bar of butter. Teddy was up there, George positioned his head in place, kicked away the sticks, so all of a sudden Teddy swung, neck bunched in the noose.
“爬上去，”乔治说，用刀作为说服手段。他将刀刃架在孩子的皮肤上，突然联想到他早晨在厨房里戴着围裙切温热黄油的母亲。泰迪上去了，乔治把他的头定位好，踢开树枝，于是泰迪突然晃荡起来，脖子缩在绞索里。
I was leaning forward in my seat.
我坐在座位上向前倾着身子。
"The rope broke," he said. "I knew it would. I just wanted to scare him because I wouldn't be had. I can't be had. You see what I mean?"
“绳子断了，”他说。“我知道会断的。我只是想吓唬他，因为我不会受人摆布。我不能受人摆布。你明白我的意思吗？”
I didn't say anything.
我没说话。
"Otherwise I feel like I'm just a doormat." He took an angry drag off his cigarette.
“不然我觉得自己就像个擦脚垫。”他愤愤地吸了一口烟。
"But do you think everyone in the whole world wants to treat you as a doormat and abuse you in some way?"
“但你认为全世界所有人都想把你当擦脚垫并以某种方式虐待你吗？”
"Absolutely," George said. "I know it."
“绝对，”乔治说。“我知道。”
"Must be tiring having to think that. You can never really let down your guard. Have you ever cried in front of someone to show that you're scared, upset?"
“那样想一定很累吧。你永远不能真正放下防备。你在别人面前哭过，展现出你的恐惧和不安吗？”
George didn't say anything. A long silence settled between as. We were a cut cord, a swarm of static.
乔治什么也没说。漫长的沉默在我们之间定格。我们是一条断了的绳子，是一阵静电。
"What's going on, George? Why is it unsafe to feel anything but defensiveness or violence in this office? Do you think I'm going to take advantage of you?" Immediately I realized I'd made a blunder by allowing him the opportunity to sexualize our interaction.
“到底怎么了，乔治？为什么在这间办公室里，除了防御或暴力，其他什么感受都是不安全的？你觉得我会利用你吗？”我立刻意识到我犯了一个错误，让他有机会将我们的互动性化了。
"You, take advantage of me? Isn't that supposed to be the other way around?" He leaned back in his chair, lit another cigarette. I saw the smoke slide from his mouth, felt it wrap around me in a blue and gauzy cloud, decking me in the moving material of a see-through dress.
“你，利用我？难道不应该是反过来的吗？”他靠在椅子上，点燃了另一支烟。我看着烟雾从他嘴里滑出，感到它像一团蓝色且薄如纱的云一样包裹着我，给我穿上了一件透视裙。
George believed that the bodies outside him were missiles, poised and poisonous. His aggressive, slit-eyed stance is a typically male phenomenon.
乔治相信他外部的身体是导弹，蓄势待发且充满毒性。他那种攻击性的、眯着眼的立场是一种典型的男性现象。
My eating disorder, the obsessive desire to be thin, thin, thin, and perfectly, poisonously poised is typically a female phenomenon.
我的饮食失调，那种想变得瘦、瘦、瘦，并且完美地、毒性地保持平衡的强迫欲望，则是典型的女性现象。
George and I were both victims of our culture's fear of the feminine, unable to lay down our system of weapons and spread our legs open to life because we learned that in this posture, we will be shamed not invigorated. We did not know how to trust what we could not dominate. And the recovering anorexic is not only in a particularly good position to articulate these truths, she is also ironically, in a particularly good position-- vis-a-vis therapy-- to treat the misogynist male. She understands, perhaps better than anyone, the urge to whip and dominate, discipline and even delete the female form.
乔治和我都是文化对女性恐惧的受害者，无法放下我们的武器系统并向生活敞开双腿，因为我们学到在这种姿态下，我们会感到羞耻而不是活力。我们不知道如何信任我们无法统治的东西。而一个康复中的厌食症患者不仅处于阐述这些真相的特别位置，而且具有讽刺意味的是，在心理治疗方面，她也处于治疗厌女男性的特别位置。她或许比任何人都理解鞭笞、统治、管教甚至删除女性形态的冲动。
For years, I was hungry but could not risk the softness of surrender. I dreamt of letting down my guard, sitting at a table on which silver dishes steamed and ingesting colors. Orange carrots, the soft wombs of tomatoes, the tangy dirt of chocolate cake. But I couldn't dare, couldn't trust enough to let myself go.
多年来，我一直感到饥饿，却不敢冒放弃抵抗的柔软风险。我梦想着放下防备，坐在摆满冒着热气银盘的桌子前，吞咽颜色。橙色的胡萝卜，番茄柔软的子宫，巧克力蛋糕那刺激的泥土气息。但我不敢，无法足够信任去让自己放手。
These are the memories that came to mind when I looked at George, rigid in his chair, his face set against the seepage of any emotion that wasn't cruel or lewd.
当我看着乔治坐在椅子上僵硬着，他的脸抵御着任何非残忍或淫秽情感的渗入时，这些记忆涌上心头。
He told me about forcing himself to rise before dawn each morning, working out two hours a day, jogging barefoot in the snow. I nodded yes, having done the same to myself.
他告诉我他强迫自己每天黎明前起床，每天锻炼两小时，在雪地里赤脚慢跑。我点头表示理解，因为我也对自己做过同样的事。
The more deeply I went into it with him, the more difficult he became. Our therapy started to evolve, so that I played a mostly silent role, while he went on and on, endlessly it seemed. About Joanne's anatomy, the six hour plow, her tight little sex.
我和他的治疗越深入，他就变得越困难。我们的治疗开始演变，我扮演了一个大多时候保持沉默的角色，而他似乎无休止地继续谈论。谈论乔安娜的解剖结构，六小时的征服，她紧致的小性器官。
What about me, I wanted to say to him. Does it occur to you that I'm a woman here? That you just might be offending me? And beneath that another smaller voice was crying, what about me? Am I not also attractive? Do I not measure up to your standards? Why not?
那我呢，我真想对他吼道。你意识到我是一个女人吗？你可能会冒犯到我吗？在那之下，另一个更小的声音在哭喊，那我呢？我不也很有吸引力吗？我不符合你的标准吗？为什么不？
I began to realize our sessions were a lot like porn, in which I, the silent subject, absorbed his fantasies, and in my featurelessness, reflected them back to him. George let me know clearly what my role in our relationship was by shifting impatiently whenever I spoke. By the quick brushing motions he made with his hands as though to sweep away my words. By interrupting me and then exploding into a tyrannical temper if I asserted my right to finish my own sentence.
我开始意识到我们的会谈很像色情作品，我作为一个沉默的对象，吸收了他的幻想，并在我毫无特征的情况下将它们反射回给他。乔治通过我说话时焦躁地挪动身体，或者通过他用手快速刷动的动作（仿佛要扫掉我的话）来明确让我知道我在我们关系中的角色。通过打断我，然后在如果我坚持自己说完句子的权利时爆发成专制的脾气。
"Quiet," he once roared at me.
“闭嘴，”他有一次对我怒吼。
And I, like a little girl, sank back down in my seat, and felt darkness grow up around me.
而我，像个小女孩一样，缩回座位里，感觉到黑暗在我周围滋生。
"I wonder if you ever think," I finally burst out to him one day, "That I might be uncomfortable with your sexual talk, with the kinds of expressions you use."
“我不知道你是否想过，”终于有一天我对他爆发道，“我可能对你的性谈话、你使用的表达方式感到不舒服。”
"But you're a shrink," George said to me. "That's what you're here for. That's your whole job."
“但你是心理医生，”乔治对我说。“这就是你在这里的原因。这就是你的全部工作。”
I wanted to reach out and slap him. "Not even in my office am I just a shrink. I am also a woman and the way you talk about my gender disgusts me."
我想伸手扇他一巴掌。“即使在我的办公室里，我也不仅仅是个心理医生。我还是一个女人，你谈论我性别的方式让我感到厌恶。”
"I wouldn't ever talk to a woman I was trying to make it with like that, but you're not supposed to--"
“我绝不会那样和我想搞定的女人说话，但你不应该是……”
"Supposed to what?"
“应该什么？”
George looked uncomfortable.
乔治看起来很不自在。
Halla-[BLEEP]-lujah, I thought.
哈利路亚，我想。
"Supposed to mind," he said.
“不应该在意，”他说。
"Surprise," I said. "I mind."
“惊喜，”我说。“我在意。”
George looked up at me, his expression confused. My face felt all red. For one moment then, our masks dropped away. I could tell by the way George was looking at me that he was, for maybe the first time, considering me not as a function, but as a feeling. I smiled at him. He nodded, hello.
乔治看着我，表情困惑。我的脸感到一阵通红。就在那一刻，我们的面具掉落了。从乔治看我的方式，我看得出他大概是第一次没有把我当作一种功能，而是作为一个有感受的人在看待。我对他笑了。他点头，哈喽。
Shortly after this encounter, George left the state for six weeks to do a series of carpentry jobs in Arizona. He returned to therapy in late May. He slumped down in his seat, looked at his lap.
这次接触后不久，乔治离开该州六周去亚利桑那州做一系列木工工作。五月下旬他回到治疗中。他瘫坐在座位上，看着自己的大腿。
"I was going to call you," he said in a low voice. I'd never heard him use that voice before.
“我本来想给你打电话，”他低声说。我以前从未听过他用那种声音说话。
"What happened?" I asked.
“发生了什么？”我问。
"She left me," George said. He shook his head. "Just like that. I called her at her parents and she says it's completely finished. Gonzo. But I'm chasing her. I'm running after her like a goddamn desperate dog. Phoning her 10, 20 times a day, bawling in her ear. It doesn't matter what I do."
“她离开了我，”乔治说。他摇了摇头。“就这样。我给她父母打电话，她说一切都结束了。彻底完了。但我还在追她。我像条该死的绝望的狗一样跑着追她。一天给她打十、二十次电话，在她耳边哭。我做什么都没用。”
"It doesn't matter what you do," I said. "Tell me more about that."
“无论你做什么都没用，”我说。“再多跟我说说。”
"I've been trying every ploy with this bitch for the past week and I'm--"
“过去一周我试了所有手段来对付这个婊子，而且我……”
"What? You're what?"
“什么？你是什么？”
"Helpless." His mouth was a bitter line of tension, but his eyes were wet.
“无助。”他的嘴唇是一条紧张的苦涩线条，但他的眼睛湿润了。
"I think that's what upsets you the most about Joanne's leaving. That you have no control. That you feel helpless to get her back."
“我想这就是乔安娜离开让你最难过的原因。因为你失去了控制。因为你感到无力挽回她。”
George, to my surprise, nodded in agreement. His own pain had made him flexible, open to vision and suggestion. For the first time in six months of treatment, I think we really talked.
令我惊讶的是，乔治点头表示同意。他自己的痛苦让他变得灵活，对视角和建议开放。在六个月的治疗中，我认为我们第一次真正进行了交谈。
The next few weeks brought some changes in George. He found himself facing an emotion he could not defend himself against. No amount of swearing or swaggering could express mourning. The pain of Joanne's leaving so suddenly broke his shield with an intensity neither of us had anticipated.
接下来的几周给乔治带来了一些改变。他发现自己面对一种他无法防御的情绪。任何咒骂或吹嘘都无法表达哀悼。乔安娜突然离去的痛苦以我们两人都没预料到的强度打破了他的盾牌。
I was drawn into George now and I told him so. In some moments I think I saw his real face, the flow of emotion across it like wind working on sand. And I grew to love him and love the strength in his slow surrender.
我被乔治吸引住了，我告诉了他。在某些时刻，我想我看到了他真实的脸，情绪像风在沙地上掠过一样在上面流动。我开始爱他，并爱他在缓慢投降中的力量。
It is August. I am 23 years old. I have never met George. I am just out of college. I weigh 88 pounds.
现在是八月。我23岁。我从未见过乔治。我刚大学毕业。我体重88磅。
When I look out my bedroom window, I can see tulips. They are the most trusting beings. They with their throats always open. Their long gold tongues hanging out. Nothing bad happens to them. The sun doesn't rape them. They don't gag on the rain.
当我看向卧室窗外时，我能看到郁金香。它们是最信任的存在。它们的喉咙总是张开的。它们长长的金舌头伸出来。没有什么坏事发生在它们身上。太阳没有强奸它们。它们不会被雨水噎住。
This day is really many months. I watch the world. I watch the natural cycle of things. Cliche as it may be, this is what cures me.
这一天其实持续了几个月。我观察这个世界。我观察事物的自然循环。尽管这很老套，但这就是治愈我的东西。
There comes a moment when recovery is religious. When a person says, all right, I will have faith. I will lay down my sword and shield and see what the world works in me.
当康复成为一种宗教时，有一个时刻会到来。当一个人说，好吧，我会拥有信仰。我会放下我的剑和盾，看看世界在我身上起什么作用。
I look away from my bedroom window and go downstairs, out onto the porch. Someone has set a table for me. Sliced strawberries lie like the tongues of maidens on a platter, wedges of cheese and bread. I put food in my mouth. For the first time in years, I swallow the softness of ice cream. I want to see if my body will blow up in disgusting fatness with this slow animal stupidity swelling in my stomach. It doesn't.
我从卧室窗户转过头，下楼来到门廊。有人为我摆好了桌子。切好的草莓像处女的舌头一样躺在盘子里，还有奶酪和面包。我把食物放进嘴里。多年来第一次，我吞咽下冰淇淋的柔软。我想看看我的身体是否会因为这种胃部膨胀的缓慢动物般的愚蠢而爆炸成恶心的肥胖。并没有。
Letting down my guard, opening my many mouths does not bring about the ruin, the rape I had feared. On the contrary, food brings vitality back to me. I feel my hair take on its sheen, grow longer as though new stalks of thought are springing from my brain. My brain, now nourished, thinks in colors instead of calories. I can run harder. My eyes are moist enough to cry.
放下防备，张开我众多的嘴，并没有带来我所恐惧的毁灭和强奸。相反，食物带回了我的活力。我感到头发恢复了光泽，长长了，仿佛新的思想之茎正从大脑中萌芽。我的大脑，现在得到滋养，以颜色而不是卡路里思考。我能跑得更快。我的眼睛湿润到足以流泪。
George started to taste-- styles, voices, times. He reported allowing himself to sleep late one morning. He started going out some night without his leather vest or black boots. Tried kissing a woman on the neck and going no farther. He brought wood home with him at the end of working days, stayed up late making small objects without any obvious functions. A box, a mobile, a chiseled plaque.
乔治开始品味——风格、声音、时间。他汇报说某天早上允许自己睡懒觉。他开始在某些晚上不穿皮背心或黑靴子出门。尝试亲吻女人的脖子但不再进一步。他工作日结束时带木头回家，熬夜制作一些没有明显功能的小物件。一个盒子，一个风铃，一块雕刻的牌匾。
One day, he came to session and told me he had met a woman, [? Blucky, ?] whom he thought he could fall in love with if only he could get over Joanne.
有一天，他来会谈，告诉我他遇见了一个女人，布鲁基，他认为如果能走出乔安娜的影响，他可能会爱上她。
"The other problem is," George said. "She's the greatest person but she's heavy. Maybe 30 pounds overweight. I've never made it with a fat woman before. You know me, I'm used to perfect curves. Thighs I can grab a hold of, someone I can flip like a doll." He gave me one of his lewd George smiles.
“另一个问题是，”乔治说。“她是个最好的人，但她很胖。可能超重30磅。我以前从没和胖女人做过。你知道我，我习惯了完美的曲线。我可以抓住的大腿，我可以像洋娃娃一样翻转的人。”他给了我一个乔治式的淫秽微笑。
I was enchanted by the idea of George with a fat woman. I had seen enough of George changed, naked, to imagine how his body would be within a fat woman's arms.
我被乔治和一个胖女人在一起的想法所迷住。我已经足够多地看到改变后的、裸露的乔治，想象他身体在胖女人怀抱中的样子。
I imagined her rocking him and him kissing her face and mouth. I could not help but see her spread legs on a bed and he, a little cowed by the site of so much, trying to touch her, allowing himself entry into the many layers of her life. He brushes her, goes up past her hip, until he touches the curved rib bone, the hard male bone taken a long time ago from the man buried and found only in the full woman's body.
我想象她摇晃着他，他亲吻她的脸和嘴。我不禁看到她分张的双腿在床上，而他，被如此多的景象吓到，试图触碰她，允许自己进入她生命的许多层面。他擦过她，越过她的臀部，直到碰到弯曲的肋骨，那个早已从被埋葬的男人身上取走，只在丰满女性身体中找到的坚硬雄性骨头。
Lauren Slater's story, "Striptease," was first published in the quarterly New Letters . It was read by actress Joy Gregory.
劳伦·斯莱特的故事《脱衣舞》首次发表在季刊《新信》上。由演员乔伊·格雷戈里朗读。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike. Contributing editor Sarah Vowell, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt and Margy Rochlin.
今天的节目由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和我制作，彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克参与制作。特约编辑萨拉·沃威尔、保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Some original scoring today by Anthony Barilla Jeff Mueller and Jason Noble.
今天的一些原始配乐由安东尼·巴里拉、杰夫·穆勒和杰森·诺布尔创作。
If you would like a copy of this or any of our programs-- they only cost $10-- call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. That's 312-832-3380.
如果您想要此节目或我们任何节目的副本——它们只需10美元——请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。号码是312-832-3380。
Our email address-- [email protected] .
我们的电子邮件地址——[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。